l'homme qui a pris l'engagement auprès
des nations unies aujourd'hui que les
casques bleus pris en otage ne serait
désormais plus enchaîné à s'appellera de
cobalt clic il à un grade de général
dans les milices serbes de bosnie je
vous propose grâce à jacques merino de
faire mieux connaissance de ces chefs de
guerre serbo bosniaque a commencé par
radovan karadic à dover karachi 49 ans
marié deux enfants et psychiatres
d'information il était avant la guerre
médecins l'hôpital de sarajevo
spécialisé dans le traitement des
dépressions l'ascension de cet homme
reste mystérieuse membre du parti
communiste yougoslave jusqu'en 1968 il
ne quitte à cette date et devient d'un
opposant à tito il n'occupe pas alors de
rôle particulier dans la vie politique
du pays
c'est en avril 1992 qui s'affirme
brutalement et soudainement comme le
chef des serbes de bosnie son credo est
simple il faut regrouper sur un même
territoire les serbes de services de
bosnie et se décline à arriver donc
qu'en ce sens apôtre de la grande serbie
joueurs de poker et amateurs de casino
radovan karadzic est un adepte du tout
ou rien il se dit prêt à lancer ses
troupes dans une guerre totale même si
cela doit se transformer en suicide
collectif
à ses côtés ratko mladic le commandant
en chef des bosses tu serbe né à l'est
de la bosnie en 1943 il est colonel de
l'armée yougoslave
quand commence la guerre entre serbes et
croates ils organisent krajina les
milices serbes et les transforme en
véritable armée il acquiert pour cela
une forte autorité sur ses troupes quand
éclate la guerre en bosnie il est nommé
général et son arrivée coïncide dans le
temps avec les pires bombardements sur
sarajevo coléreux l'homme est aussi
intarissable développant à la première
occasion de longues tirades sur
l'histoire du peuple serbe et rappelant
chaque fois que son père a été tué par
les croiser en 1945
ces deux hommes qui souvent sont en
conflit ont une caractéristique commune
ils savent que s'ils perdent ils seront
jugés pour crimes contre l'humanité